she ate it are you a 12-step program
right now because what you're saying to
me right now are things that we talked
about cleaning your side of the street
it's a part of the steps actually to
make amends in that way you know it's a
part of every religion now every single
religion golden rule is treat others how
you want to be treated yeah and if
somebody made some mistakes and they
came back to you and said I'm pologize
like if man if my mom would apologize to
me about some of the things she said to
me and did to me well I think our
dynamic would be a lot stronger you know
you're so right after 35 years my mom
finally apologized to me two weeks ago
for all the [ __ ] it was it was like an
umbrella statement dude like look I'm
sorry
and it took 35 years but I didn't
realize that's all I needed to hear
something so simple it relieved me it
was like this thing my chest felt light
again and all of a sudden I could feel
myself treating her differently in 35
years mm-hmm
is your mom not a part of your life
right oh no my mom is definitely a part
of my life all right I had to realize
that she has she had a brain injury she
has mental illness that you know I might
not ever get an apology from her but I
need to realize you know how I treat her
might be how if I have children or I
adopt kids or if somebody decides they
want to take care that's how they're
gonna treat me yeah you know whatever
you give that's what you get back so
like in my book I talk about like
hopefully I make enough money where I
can get her out the mental institution
get her in a place and hire other people
to deal with her ass and I don't have to
deal with the in that is what I have
done like I got her the best nurses the
best doctors I'm watching her transform
having realizations writing letters
about the guilt that she's felt about
not raising her children about putting
all this on me she says not apologized
but what she has done is like the one
thing I've been like you know doing ah
so I wondered like a lot of times am i
doing all this just for her approval and
kind of yeah yeah and you know the first
time I ever was on television doing
stand-up with bill Bellamy's who's got
jokes and I showed it to her and she was
in an institution and she her response
was my coochie make stars and I thought
this is gonna be the closest thing I get
to I'm proud of ya and that was what the
14 15 years ago and then recently you
know I took her to the premiere of night
school and she got to see Kevin Hart and
all these people you know saying it they
love me they appreciate me that they're
glad that you know she's my mom like you
know they're giving her love and at the
end of the night she gave me the biggest
hug and she said now I'm proud I'm proud
of you that's what I was like enough me
to be like okay whatever I'm invest in
here is working you know I still want my
[ __ ] apology that time you beat me on
my feet with the [ __ ] back scrubber
like I really you want to no pain get
whooped on the bottom of your feet you
can feel it in every organ will she ever
don't know yeah I don't know I still can
feel the pain when I think of it it's
like it [ __ ] hurts in my intestines
you know myself
it was bad yeah but it I understand pain
I understand what real hurt is and what
people try to inflict on me on the
internet or they try to destroy my name
or destroy my career has it's nothing
compared to the person the first person
I ever loved
my mother's the first person I ever
loved and the first person to destroy my
soul like destroy my heart so anybody
who don't know me and you want to talk
[ __ ] about me go for it yeah making me
more popular you introducing me to you
17 followers for it yeah hurt me no more
than I've already been hurt I think you
might be causing everything that you're
saying is exactly the same thing I went
through with my mom where it's like it's
I could not on it was so deep my love
for her I I remember telling her like I
could never love a boy more than I love
you but she was the one person that just
always made my mouth bleed always
belittled me always did these things to
just break me down as a child and that
hold chasing the love thing just is
perpetuated when you're an adult yeah
you keep reenact in your childhood it's
a it's a pattern and I think ultimately
I always look back at her to see to see
if there's some level of approval there
you know and um and you're not maybe
you'll never get an apology but you're
not wrong about that apology he feeling
like the most healing thing in the world
right it is and you know I don't I don't
know if she'll ever apologize and and
that's another thing I had to learn like
probably about five or six years ago
like I can't expect someone who hurt me
to apologize I have to apologize to
myself first for allowing myself to even
be in that situation because I think
even I think you can remove your so
especially now like kids can call the
police in here be put in a different
home immediately so if if you're in a
situation that is tumultuous that is
hurtful that is bad and you allow
yourself to stay there you have to
apologize to yourself - you're a child
yeah but you're your child no but still
yeah but still you know I know you're
talking and I don't know any better you
were you were in this situation you were
a victim and you're the innocent one
right and it happened to you and your
child and I don't see even when I was
see that box right there was a box no
don't bring up just show it
see that's my dad he died in August okay
that dude used to beat me with golf
clubs knocked my mom's teeth out and a
month ago my mom goes he he he told me
that he regrets how you returned she
told me right and I never got an apology
for him and um I used to blame myself my
whole life yeah right because I feel
like I deserved it I didn't deserve it
no no you we were innocent right
children and you know what that is on
top of it I went I had to I don't know
but you know but in I had to go to an
institution I month ago because I wanted
to die I'm not f him I wanted to die and
so that when I went to the therapy place
in Arizona they made me go to a
build-a-bear and build my original child
hmm that's me innocent Bobby Lee I mean
with none of the trauma just want to be
nurtured and loved and all that stuff
that's what we are
yeah when we're born yeah you know but
your did mom didn't make a storm
[Laughter]
that dude man